en raison de l'épidémie de covile 19
l'académie de versailles estime que le
taux d'absentéisme des enseignants et
personnels administratifs est monté à 10
% voire à 15% et souvent les professeurs
ne pouvant plus se rendre en classe sont
rarement remplacé par contre ce qui est
plus difficile c'est au niveau des
professeurs quand ils sont pas là bas
ils ont du mal à être remplacé donc on
doit garder nos enfants un peu à la
dernière minute donc ça c'est assez
difficile à gérer et après c'est pareil
au niveau de la cantine des fois y'a pas
assez de personnel donc on nous demande
de les garder donc on faut qu'on
s'arrange donc ça c'est un peu compliqué
on est confronté tout ça la réalité du
manque de personnel le ministre peut
toujours parler de remplaçant mais les
prend place on les voit pas on les
voyait pas déjà avant et avec le
le coc vide c'est encore plus cher
encore pire depuis le début de l'année
scolaire l'académie de versailles a déjà
recruté trois mille trois cents
personnes mais pour pallier le manque
d'effectif dû à la crise sanitaire elle
a lancé depuis début janvier une vaste
opération de recrutement depuis la
reprise de janvier
nous avons passé un cran supplémentaire
pour aller chercher d'autres personnes
notamment des étudiants qui seraient
qualifiés il faut une licence pour
enseigner mais également des personnes
retraitées et puis d'autres contractuels
qui ont les qualifications depuis deux
semaines nous avons recruté un petit peu
plus de 200 nouvelles personnes et au
total nous en faut encore il nous en
faudrait encore 300 pour compléter nos
fins outre les enseignants le personnel
administratif et les surveillants sont
également en tension il ya un autre
besoin qui est grande pour nous c'est ce
qu'on appelle les assistants d'éducation
ce sont les surveillants dans les
collèges dans les lycées l'année
dernière nous avions mis en place des
équipes mobiles de surveillants qu'ils
pouvaient se déplacer aux furieux au gré
des besoins des collèges et des lycées
d'un établissement à un autre nous avons
plus d'une centaine de postes à pourvoir
en ce sens certains territoires des
yvelines sont plus touchés la rectrice
de l'académie de versailles évoque
notamment les villes de
chanteloup-les-vignes aubergenville ou
encore ben